AMONG MY GUESTS.
BUT FIRST A VERY IMPORTANT
OPENING STATEMENT.
I'M A BELIEVER.
I BELIEVE IN THE SYSTEM AND I
BELIEVE IN JUSTICE.
I DEDICATED MORE THAN 30 YEARS
TO THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND THE ASSIGNMENT OF BLAME.
TONIGHT I'M NOT ANGRY.
I'M JUST DUMB FOUND AND
DISHEARTENED AND DISAPPOINTED.
OVER THE LONG AWAITED, OFTEN
DELAYED INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
REPORT ON THE ACTIONS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
FBI IN THE HANDLING OF THE
HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION.
THE REPORT'S CONCLUSION, 568
PAGES LATER, FBI DIRECTOR JAMES
COMEY WAS INSUBORDINATE.
THERE WERE A FEW MISTAKES
ANDERRORS IN JUDGMENT.
THOUGH THERE WAS SOME BIAS,
THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE OF BIAS IN
THE EMAIL INVESTIGATION.
THIS REPORT MIMICS COMEY'S
CONCLUSIONS IN THE EMAIL CASE.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL AND COMEY
MAKE OUT A PROVABLE CASE, THEN
CONCLUDE THERE IS NO CASE.
NOTHING CHANGES.
THE DEEP STATE HARD AT WORK.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU, BUT I'M
SO TIRED OF LESSONS LEARNED.
THEY SAY COMEY CHIEF GRADE THE
RULE.
DEVIATED FROM THE RULES?
COMEY AND HIS FBI CABAL FIXED A
CASE.
HILLARY NOT INDICTED FOR HER
CRIMES YET AN EFFORT TO FRAME
DONALD TRUMP FOR NO CRIME.
AND NO BIAS IN THE CONCLUSION
BECAUSE SOMEONE SAID YES, I WAS
BIASED OR SAID SIMPLY I AM NOT
BIASED?
THAT'S IT.
EVERY DAY CASES ARE TRIED FOR
MURDER WHERE THERE IS NO
ADMISSION OF GUILT, ONLY
DENIALS.
BUT JURORS DECIDE THE ACCUSED
INTENTIONS BASED ON WHAT THEY
SAY, WHAT THEY DO WHAT THEY
DON'T DO.
DETERMINE SOMETHING ONE'S INTENT
IS NOTE THAT DIFFICULT.
TAKE A LOOK AT THESE TEXTS.
WE'LL STOP HIM FROM BEING
PRESIDENT.
IT'S LIKE AN INSURANCE POLICY IN
THE UNLIKELY EVENT YOU DIE WHEN
YOU ARE 40.
HILLARY SHOULD WIN 100 MILLION
TO ZERO.
AMERICA WILL GET WHAT THE PUBLIC
DESERVES.
HERE IS A NEW ONE FROM AN FBI
LAWYER.
VIVALE RESISTANCE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE A WOK THE
SCIENTIST TO UNDERSTAND THOSE
STATEMENTS.
THEY IMPLY UNEQUIVOCALLY
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE OFFICIAL
ACTION TO IMPACT THE ELECTION.
HOW DO YOU PLEDGE RESISTANCE
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT WHILE YOU
ARE INVESTIGATING IT.
THE COMEY DIDN'T JUST DEVIATE
FROM WELL ESTABLISHED PRACTICES.
HE DIDN'T EVEN DO AN
INVESTIGATION.
HE COVERED FOR IT BY HAVING THE
SAME PEOPLE HANDLE THE HILLARY
CASE AND THE TRUMP FRAMEUP.
THIS CASE IS NOT ABOUT MISTAKES
OR ERRORS IN JUDGMENT.
IT'S ABOUT A DEEP STATE TRYING
TO DRAG A TRUCK ACROSS THE
PRESIDENTIAL FINISH LINE AND
TRYING TO DESTROY THE MAN
AMERICANS WANTED IN THE OVAL
OFFICE.
EXAMPLE.
JIM COMEY SAID HE HAD TO STEP
INTO LORETTA LYNCH'S ROLE
BECAUSE SHE WOULDN'T RECUSE
HERSELF AFTER SECRETLY MEETING
WITH BILL CLINTON ON THE TARMAC.
THAT'S BALONEY.
HE STEPPED INTO HER ROLE TO
DECLARE HILLARY NOT GUILTY, AND
JIM IF YOU ARE SUCH A CHAMPION
OF TRUTH AND JUSTICE.
WHY DID YOU GO ALONG WITH LYNCH
CALLING A YEAR-LONG CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION A MATTER.
WHY DID YOU SAY HILLARY WAS
EXTREMELY CARELESS SO AS TO NOT
USE THE WORDS CRIMINALLY
NEGLIGENT.
AND YOU PUNTED SAYING YOU DON'T
THINK GROSSLY NEGLIGENCE
APPLIES.
FIRST-YEAR LAW STUDENTS ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY LAUGHED AT YOU.
YOU TAKE A CASE FROM LOCAL FIELD
AGENTS TO INVESTIGATE AND GIVE
AWAY IMMUNITY LIKE CANDY.
INVESTIGATORS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
LAUGHED AT YOU.
AND WHEN YOU FOUND HILLARY'S
DELETED EMAILS THAT WERE MARKED
C FOR CLASSIFIED YOU DECIDE TO
BELIEVE HER WHEN SHE SAID IT WAS
ONLY A REFERENCE TO THE LETTER C
IN THE ALPHABET IN SPITE OF THE
FACT THERE WAS NO A OR B BEFORE
C.
PEOPLE IN THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY LAUGHED AT YOU.
YOU WROTE PANE EXONERATION OF
HILLARY MONTHS BEFORE YOU
INTERVIEWED HER.
ATTORNEYS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
LAUGHED AT YOU.
COME ON, JIM, YOU ACQUITTED HER
BECAUSE LIKE HILLARY, YOU, LYNCH
AND OBAMA COMMUNICATED
GOVERNMENT INFORMATION VIA
PRIVATE EMAILS.
AND YOU PLACED AS MANY TRUMP
HATERS AS YOU COULD.
I WANT TO KNOW FROM THIS
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT, WHY
DON'T WE KNOW WHAT JUDGE SIGNED
THE FISA WARRANT?
WHO RENEWED THE FISA WARRANT?
AND WHAT ACTIONS THEY ARE
TAKING?
AND WHY WAS PETER STRZOK
ARGUABLY THE MOST OF CORRUPT FBI
AGENT IN AMERICAN POLITICAL
HISTORY PUT ON THE MUELLER TEAM
TO DESTROY DONALD TRUMP WITH IS
GIRLFRIEND LISA PAGE?
WHY IS HE STILL WORK AND WHY AM
I PAYING HIS SALARY.
WHY IS ROD ROSENSTEIN ALLOWED TO
REFUSE TO PROVIDE RECORDS AND
DOCUMENTS TO CONGRESS.
AND WHY IS HE THREATENING TO
SUBPOENA RECORDS OF THOSE IN
CONGRESS WITHOUT ANY CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
WHY DIDN'T ROSENSTEIN HAND OVER
THE MOST OF INCRIMINATING OF THE
TEXTS, NO, HE WON'T WIN
PRESIDENT.
WE'LL STOP HIM.
WHY ARE THE DOJ AND THE FBI
ALLOWED TO LIE TO A FEDERAL
JUDGE AND I WE HAVE NO EMAILS
BETWEEN US ON THE LORETTA LYNCH
BILL CLINTON TARMAC MEETING.
WHY CAN LORETTA LYNCH LIE AND
USE A PERSONAL EMAIL AND A FAKE
NAME FOR GOVERNMENT BUSINESS.
HOW MANY TIMES DOES SOMEONE HAVE
TO LIE TO AN INSPECTOR GENERAL
BEFORE THEY ARE JUST NOT
BELIEVABLE.
WHY DOES HILLARY CLINTON JUST
DAYS AFTER SHE MEETS BILL
CLINTON ON THE TARMAC?
WHY DOES THE I.G. NOT RECOMMEND
A LEAK INVESTIGATION WHEN THERE
ARE 657 PHONE CALLS FROM A
REPORTER TO A TOP FBI OFFICIAL.
SRNLTS THE FBI SUPPOSED TO
FIGURE THAT STUFF OUT ON ITS
OWN.
I'M WORRIED.
I'M REALLY WORRIED.
THIS REPORT IS NOTHING MORE THAN
A WHITE WASH BY THE DEEP STATE
ITSELF.
THERE ARE GREAT PEOPLE IN THE
FBI, MEN AND WOMEN, AND I HAVE
HAD THE HONOR OF WORKING WITH
THEM.
BUT THEY ARE EMBARRASSED BECAUSE
THEY KNOW HOW BAD COMEY AND
COMPANY DESTROYED AMERICA'S
CONFIDENCE IN THAT ESTEEMED FBI.
AND THERE ARE GREAT PEOPLE IN
GOVERNMENT, MANY OF WHOM YOU
HAVE SEEN ON THIS SHOW.
CONGRESSMAN RON DESANTIS, JIM
JORDAN, MARK ME DEES, LEE
ZELDIN, LINDSEY GRAHAM, RON
JOHNSON, CHUCK GRASSLEY.
THESE PEOPLE ARE FIGHTING THE
DEEP STATE AND OBSTRUCTIONIST
DEMOCRATS LIKE PELOSI, SCHUMER
AND SCHIFF STARE INTO THE
CAMERAS AND TURN TRUTH ON ITS
HEAD.
THEY ARE DEMON RATS.
UNTIL THE REPUBLICANS LEARN TO
FIGHT LIKE THEY DO AND GO WITH A
NARRATIVE NO ONE VEERS FROM.
THEY AND SOCIALISM WILL RUN AMOK
IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE NEED PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON WHO
BELIEVE IN TRUTH AND JUSTICE AND
ARE NOT OFFENDED BY THE TERM LAW
AND ORDER.
THIS IS NOT A BANANA REPUBLIC.
THIS IS THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA WITH A JUSTICE SYSTEM
THAT NEEDS TO BE PROTECTED.
IT'S TIME FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT INTERESTED IN SUPPORTING
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO GET OUT OF
HIS WAY.
THAT MEANS YOU, JEFF SESSIONS.
IT'S TIME FOR TO YOU PUT ON YOUR
BIG BOY PANTS AND START ACTING
LIKE THE A.G.
IF YOU CAN'T GET ON BOARD WITH
THIS PRESIDENT, THEN GET THE
HELL OUT OF HIS WAY.
LET ME BE CLEAR TO ALL YOU
CRITICS.
I'M NOT LOOKING FOR THAT JOB.
I'M AN ORDINARY AMERICAN WHO WAS
BROUGHT UP TO BELIEVE IN TRUTH
AND JUSTICE.
LIKE THOUSANDS AND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF MEN AND WOMEN WHO
WESTERN JUST DAMN EMBARRASSED
AND HANG OUR HEADS IN SHAME WITH
THE LIKES OF COMEY AND HIS CABAL
AS WELL AS THE IMPOTENT
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT WHICH
IS NOTHING MORE THAN PROOF THE
DEEP STATE IS ALIVE AND WELL IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
THAT'S MY OPEN.